3 qu'isabelle est prête à isabelle on a
une petite chance pour elle isabelle ma
chérie comme à fabas à la vision du
futur marié rosart vous je vous dis tout
intriguée croyez que ça ne fait de
l'effet ben merci madame ça fait
extrêmement plaisir mon isad amour ma
chérie eux
alors on a une petite surprise pour toi
isa est ce que est ce qu'il a peu avancé
souplesse qu'on peut le montrer ça que
les manettes de droite
est ce qu'on peut demander les yeux de
d'isabelle s'il vous plaît est ce que
quelqu'un m'attende à la bnr un peu il
me dit elle est prête est ce qu'on peut
et est-ce qu'on peut s'occuper des âmes
amis merci isabelle vous a fait une
petite surprise
regardez devant quoi vous êtes attention
enlever le regard des bars garder mon
calme
oui vous êtes comme quoi à vous êtes
devant rtl
je suis devant la première radio de
france
c'est dingue non tu avales vous êtes
dans cette radio magnifique paire t elle
la deuxième radio de france
isabelle la première première
alors isabelle reverdy on a une petite
surprise pour vous c'est parti attention
aux noms on va regarder ce qu'on a fait
joli
[Rires]
[Musique]
allez vous l'avez très courts cdd avec
allez vas-y manille
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais dans le temps allez-vous pca les
pas de souchez voilà ma dit y aura
certainement passé